hey Doug what's up fellas Sam deep DP by
the way good to see you back in the
mothership in the commercial that is
awesome that is a system that's so
amazing it's such good work by you thank
uh and the hair looks spectacular I mean
really really good I don't know I mean
no I know most that's natural but the
makeup artist and that is I need to get
one of those now this is how you start
out a phone call all right now lower the
boom on me Doug no it's on you it's on
Polly's lukewarm cake with all these
running backs go in the first round I
mean look around the look around the
league and it's certain what for example
at the at the Atlanta Falcons right they
have two running backs I mean Tevin
Coleman has been outstanding when he's
been healthy they have two running backs
now they were taking in the first couple
rounds and you know you go back last
year in the draft and everybody in the
state of Georgia wanted them to take
Todd Gurley well what would you rather
have you know um vic beasley who gives
them a pass rusher or Todd Gurley a
singular running back you'd rather have
multiple options there I think there can
be fewer and fewer as good as Ezekiel it
has been and he's been spectacular like
better than advertised the fact is that
uh you know I kind of think you could
put anybody behind that Dallas Cowboys
offensive line and still have a very
very productive running game and at that
tense you know at where they drafted
they could have had Jalen Ramsey and
what that teams lacking is a shutdown
corner so I think the opposite is true i
think that the evaluation the running
back is just beginning and it's going to
continue what would the cowboys be just
as good that's throwing water on your
warm take us what the Cowboys be just as
good or better if they had Jalen Ramsey
instead of Ezekiel Elliott probably
probably I mean it's hard look the part
the point that you made which is the
best one is uzuki oh it's at three down
back and he's as good in pass protection
that's what all that football guys like
dude the college kids usually come out
and they think it's all about what you
do when you get the football it's a lot
like basketball players who all they
think about is you know your value is
what you do when you have the basketball
when the truth is if you can't protect
the quote
back you know if you can't play on third
down you don't have the same value
Paulie do you want to respond to Doug
Gottlieb I think Doug has a great point
I think it's gonna be more of a run on
offensive lineman this year but there's
I'm talking later in the first rap
because McCaffrey won't go to the second
dis Dalvin cook go top ten yes no doubt
no no and I think he's great but I'd say
note that the and then Paul you just you
stepped into a great a better warm take
the two best teams maybe in football
right now are the raiders and the
cowboys and what do they have in common
they both have great offensive lines and
then and going back to DP you were
asking why our quarterbacks bus and the
answer is this a quarterback can't play
you see him with a clipboard and a hat
on if a left tackle can't play he moves
over to right guard or right tackle you
can still get some sort of that the
cornerback can't play you play MIT maybe
nickel corner where you make him do a
safety they still have some sort of
value and you don't see them like you
see a quarterback who stinks yeah but we
also if you take a running back high or
a wide receiver up high they don't get
nearly the criticism if you take a
quarterback up high so we we we give too
much credit to the quarterback too much
blame to the quarterback but the GMs are
the ones this is their job I know and we
never say man that GM is a bust because
look at what he did it's that
quarterback is a bust not the team that
drafted him I mean dak dak Prescott
drops to the fourth round ugh how does
that happen if everybody does their work
but you might wait you watch Colin and
Polly you guys watch college look like i
watch Mississippi State I love dak
Prescott but he wasn't that accurate
like nobody and and what would dak
Prescott look like if he played with the
regular offensive line we didn't have
all day to throw dnet dez bryant he
didn't have a secure elit they did have
you know one of the great tight ends
we've had in football so it's a it's all
really hard metric to measure out like
if you put him behind the Seahawks
offensive line would he be anywhere near
as productive as Russell Wilson has been
the answer is no Russell Wilson's back
there running for his life so it's a
hard way here's one last thing we're
talking you're talking college football
yeah and here's the here's the irony to
it Michigan gets
credit for beating Colorado right that's
become that's a signature out of
conference win yeah right and Washington
gets rightfully punished because they're
out of conference strength of schedule
was 117 out of 118 118 teams they played
117 strongest out of conference schedule
right they scheduled Rutgers but when
that game was scheduled Rutgers was good
and when the colorado game is scheduled
for michigan colorado was essentially
rutgers of the pac-12 they were terrible
for a decade and it's just weird that we
reward like oh well they went out and
they played somebody I don't League like
they weren't trying to they were trying
to they used to play Notre Dame now they
don't and the crazy thing is had they
played Notre Dame this year that would
have been a good win that would have
been a that would have been a bad
strength or schedule in man don't use
all of your content save it for your
show my show is not as good as yours
nice popular [ __ ] my hair doesn't look
as good as you're twice my age your hair
is better that's not there I appreciate
that who's got a better jumper mine's
pretty good yo you you specialize in the
low feeling of in the low ceilings or
the man cave get a real gym and look I'm
20 minutes down the road from you I got
a real gym I got a I got a I got a
little court outside my house we can go
anytime you want to show me that wet
jump shot out in the real elements or a
real gym you're welcome I don't do road
trips man everything is a home court
advantage dog thanks thanks for calling
in talk later DP all right it's doug
gottlieb the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]